Hi, in this video I will show you how we can work with the track elements from JavaScript,
just to know which track has been loaded and which track is active.
For that, we will manipulate different properties of the HTML track element from JavaScript.
The first thing I am going to do is to add a small div at the end of the document for
displaying the different track statuses. I added a div here called trackStatusesDiv with a
heading... I am going to add some CSS to visualize this area.
So like that, we will have the description of the track here. I added a border and some
margins and so on. From JavaScript, we can not do anything before
the page has been loaded, so I am adding a window.onload listener, and all the treatments
will be in this function. So the first thing I am going to do is get these track elements
here... and I am going to get them in a variable called htmlTracks. So how can I get them?
I'm going to stop the automatic refresh on JSBin for the moment.
So, querySelectorAll is a function that will return a collection with all the tracks, an array with all the tracks,
all the HTML elements. So there, I am going to call a function called displayTrackStatuses
that I write here. I will first iterate on these tracks and display
in the console the different values. So we are doing a loop.
I will first just display something in the console.
I am going to add a current track, it will be easier.
So, I can write currentTrack.label for example, that will display the value of the different attributes.
This is just for checking that my code is OK.
So I open the console, I have got one error...
So if I click here "Run with JS" I can see that it's working.
What I can display is the label, I can also display the kind... you remember the kind: subtitles,
subtitles, chapters for the different tracks subtitles, subtitles and chapters and I can
also display the language with srclang. So English, Deutsch (for German).
I can also display what is called the status. It is readyState, this is a property you can
use only from JavaScript. It says that for track number 1, the value is 0, for track number 2 is 2,
for track number 3, it's 0. 2 means that the track is loaded and 0 means
that the track is not available. So we've got the first track, the English
subtitles are not available: status readyState 0 and we've got the German subtitles that
have been loaded because is has the default attribute, and we showed that in Google Chrome
the track with the default attribute is loaded when the page is loaded.
So this is how we can consult the different statuses of a track from JavaScript.
I am going to copy and paste some code for just displaying this in a nicer way here.
So, this is how we can display the different statuses and I can add a button that will call this
just to refresh the different statuses. Let's add a button, we call it refresh, and
when we click on it, we will call displayTrackStatuses. If I click here... just checking there is no error…
it will refresh this thing. So now I am going to try this code with Safari;
because you remember Safari has a menu for changing the different tracks. I prepared
that already, so here I can start playing the same video that has Deutsch subtitles loaded
by default, you can see that here. If I choose English subtitles now, and I refresh
track statuses: you can see that the English subtitles are loaded now and the Deutsch subtitles
are also available. So, we are going to use these different attributes
for forcing some tracks to load programmatically from JavaScript and this will enable us
to make a sort of menu for choosing the different tracks. I will explain that in a next video.